[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
claire Planchard bonjour Claire merci
beaucoup d'être avec ns rédactrices en
chef au groupe ébra les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France Erwan
lestron bonjour herwan merci également
d'être là directeur conseil chez odoxa
et on va parler comme tous les mois du
baromètre au doxa pour Public Sénat et
la presse régionale sur les élections
européennes le RN fait la course en tête
creusant l'écart avec la majorité
présidentielle et tous les autres partis
qui sont en dessous de 10 % vous nous
décrypterez tout ça mais d'abord on va
revenir évidemment sur l'information de
cette soirée agitée à l'Assemblée
nationale où la commission mixte
paritaire sur le texte immigration n'a
toujours pas abouti Alex on va voir que
le plus dur est peut-être à venir et oui
on verra que le programme de cette
journée de ce mi s'annonce très chargé
pour les pour les parlementaires pour
essayer d'aboutir à un accord sur ce
projet de loi immigration et on en parle
tout de suite dans ce
[Musique]
club soirée agité hier à l'Assemblée
nationale de coup de théâtre en
suspension la droite et la majorité
présidentielle n'ont toujours pas trouvé
à l'heure actuelle d'accord sur le texte
on va voir le récit de cette soirée avec
cécileou
beaucoup pensaient que l'affaire se
réplié hier soir mais à minuit 30 les
travaux de la commission mixte paritaire
sont suspendus jusqu'à ce matin 10h30
les négociations patinent des
l'ouverture de la commission mixte
paritaire à 17h une première suspension
est demandé au bout de quelques minutes
visiblement LR et majorité
présidentielle ne s'étaiit pas compris
sur les aides personnalisé au logement
versé aux étrangers c'est simplement
parce que dans les discussions entre la
première ministre et certains groupes et
notamment le groupe des Républicains ce
sujet a été considéré comme abordé par
les uns et pas abordé par les autres
c'était une discussion orale et le jour
au moment où elle été actée par écrit on
s'est rendu compte que la position
divergit l'attence va durer 4 He les
députés renaissan sont convoqués à
Matignon par ellisabeth borne qui tient
à ce qu'un accord soit trouvé à la
reprise des travaux à 21h les LR
attendent un pas de la majorité
présidentielle que la majorité est du
mal que la majorité doit faire un grand
travail pour partir de leur version
initiale pour rejoindre la version des
républicains je l'entends je l'entends
c'est pas forcément facile nous on a dû
avaler énormément de coup l'œuvre ces
dernières années depuis 2017 mais c'est
le jeu de la démocratie si la commission
mixte paritaire valide plusieurs mesures
en fin de soirée la question des aPL
reste à trancher c'est normal qu'il a un
peu de cristallisation c'est une
négociation qui n'est pas simple sur
lequel chacun a ses lignes rouges chacun
donne une concession à l'autre et
évidemment on essaie de trouver le point
d'quip donc c'est pas anormal qu'il a de
la discussion c'est normal qu' qu'elle
nécessite un peu de un peu de temps tout
se joue ce matin si les députés et
sénateurs trouvent un accord le texte
pourra être présenté aux assemblées cet
après-midi sinon il sera
abandonné clair on le voit il y a eu ça
a été compliqué hier la soirée à
l'Assemblée il y a une suspension
immédiate ça a repris à 21h ça a été
suspendu il y a toujours pas d'accord à
l'heure actuelle est-ce qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à un tel scénario la journée
Ava été avait arrive avec un c'est un
peu comme réglé comme du papier à
musique on nous avait dit voilà réunion
dans l'après-midi vote le lendemain
solennel à l'Assemblée au Sénat et on a
vu que très très vite en fait malgré les
les déclarations officielles disant
qu'on était plus proche d'un accord que
d'un désaccord de la part de de Gérald
daranin il y a eu des points des points
vraiment de de crispation notamment sur
la restriction on a entendu des des
allocations au aux personnes immigrées
donc ce délai de 5 ans voilà pour la
présence sur le territoire français et
on voit bien que là il y a est-ce que
c'est un jeu de poker menteur qui qui
dit vrai est-ce que vraiment il y avait
eu un deal avant est-ce que quelques
interlocuteurs n'ont pas respecté leurs
engagements il y a vraiment là voilà
dans dans ce h clos eu des tractations
qui n'ont pas permis d'avancer donc ben
on repart donc à 10h30 ce matin et
effectivement le plus dur est reste à
venir parce que là le le temps presse on
sait que le président voulait terminer
avant même son déplacement en Jordanie
donc avant avant les les congés de fin
d'année il y a voilà donc c'est c'est
vraiment sent que là le gouvernement
joue gros quoi ouais et quel regard les
Français peuvent avoir sur tout çawan on
sait dans les sondages en tout cas que
les Français sont majoritairement
favorables à ce texte et qu'ils veulent
plus de fermeté sur l'immigration on en
avait parlé le mois dernier comment ils
peuvent percevoir ce qui se passe ces
dernières heures ce qu'on ce qu'on avait
vu la semaine dernière quand on
interrogait les les Français c'est que
uniquement 3/ 10 d'entre eux après
l'adoption de la motion de rejet
souhaitait un abandon pur et simple du
projet de loi immigration quand même 7/
10 qui veulent une loi immigration et
là-dedans une grande majorité nous
disait souhaiter un un projet plus à
droite plus proche de la version des
sénateurs ça c'est une point de vue de
l'opinion des Français aujourd'hui par
contre il y a le poison lent de
l'ingouvernabilité et ça aussi ça ça a
du poids parce que en fin de semaine
dernière les Français étaient
majoritaires à souhaiter un départ de
Gérald armanin du ministère de
l'intérieur mais aussi 6/ 10 à être
favorable à un changement de Premier
ministre à une dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a aussi le
risque des frondeurs s'installent chez
Renaissance c'est c'est une chose qu'on
avait vu qui avait un peu détérioré le
quinquen de de François Hollande c'est
frondeur au sein même de de son camp
donc il y a le poison l de
l'ingouvernabilité qui peut être un vrai
enjeu pour l'exécutif au-delà du fait
que les Français sont globalement assez
favorables aux mesures rigides qui sont
proposées dans le le projet tel qu'il a
été revu par les sénateurs ou et vous
avez posé la question du rejet hein du
projet de loi immigration on va le voir
53 % des Français pensent que le rejet
est une bonne chose oui alors c'est un
accueil assez schizophrénique des des
Français c'est peut-être la la facture
qui arrive quelques mois après du 493
pour la réforme des retraites c'est que
il y avait il y avait un rejet des
Français sur la question de la méthode
et aussi peut-être une certaine volonté
dans une partie d'électorale d'infliger
un camouflé à la majorité présidentielle
par plus que sur le fond du texte sur le
fond du texte il y a pas de débat les
Français sont beaucoup moins clivés que
la classe politique sur ces différents
sujets soutiennent favorablement mais à
plus de 6 personnes sur 10 l'ensemble
des mesures envisagées ce qui a plutôt
été apprécié chez les Français c'est
cette horizontalité de la politique et
cette capacité des oppositions en
servant du en même temps au détriment du
président à faire reculer l'exécutif
est-ce que aussi bien l'exécutif clair
que la droite aurait beaucoup à perdre
en cas d'échec de ce texte d'immigration
bah pour la majorité notamment pour
Emmanuel Macron c'était une réforme
politique qui était dans son programme
donc et qu'il a voulu un peu être une
incarnation de son en même temps
c'est-à-dire où il y avait à la fois des
mesures plus en plus à gauche hein voilà
notamment parlait beaucoup de la
régularisation des des travills dans les
c'est en tension voilà et en même temps
cette volonté de montrer qu'on essaie de
maîtriser les flux migratoir et l'échec
là de ces tractations dans de cette
navette entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat
montre toute la difficulté de cet
équilibre et on l'a entendu monur reill
parler tout à l'heure est-ce que on peut
arriver justement à concilier sur un
sujet comme ça ces deux ces deux
équilibrés est- ce que vous disiez sur
la la perception des Français
aujourd'hui on a une droitisation de
l'opinion sur le sujet
retient voilà les clés de cette de ce
texte et en même temps voilà il y a un
risque de fracturation vraiment très
très forte de la majorité et on parlait
des frondurs là aujourd'hui il y a entre
20 je crois députés 20 et 30 qui dirait
qu'il ne voteraiit pas parce que c'est
contraire à leur à leur valeurs à leurs
conviction il faut pas oublier quand
même que en 2017 ce parti est vené
surtout de sympathisants socialistes
voilà donc avec une certaine
positionnement sur ces questions
notamment de préférence nationales qui
sont perçus comme vraiment un héritage
du du Front national enfin des questions
vraiment central et de de voilà de deux
valeurs et on voit que là effectivement
si on n arrive pas c'est que LR n'aura
pas montré sa capacité à vraiment tenir
le jeu et et et et Emmanuel Macron l'a
dit il laerait il abandonnerait ce texte
qui était qui était central pour lui
ouais et du coup ça poserait la question
de la crise politique et de comment en
sortir là aussi vous avez posé des
questionsan les Français ils veulent à
une grande majorité un référendum sur
cette question de l'immigration sur
cette question l'immigration ils étaient
tro/4 d'entre eux à être favorable à un
réforme une réforme sur un référendum
sur les questions de de l'immigration
mais ils souhaitent aller plus loin ils
veulent vraiment un changement de cadre
une meilleure prise en compte de
l'ensemble des sensibilités qui
s'exprime à l'Assemblée nationale et en
ça ils sont très favorable à un
changement de Premier ministre à une
dissolution à un espèce de changement de
règle du jeu c'est vrai que l'initiative
d'ampleur qui est annoncée par Emmanuel
Macron pour la rentrée 2024 elle devra
nécessairement prendre en compte ses
attentes d'ailleurs un mot sur le
référendum sur l'immigration car c'est
vraiment un point de débat entre la
droite le rassemblement national et
Emmanuel Macron l'lr et le RN souhaitent
et bien changer la consti institution
pour pouvoir organiser un référendum sur
ce sujet de l'immigration ce qui n'est
pas possible actuellement au début
Emmanuel Macron avait plutôt une
approche plutôt favorable he car il
voulait donner des gages à la droite
mais il a vu qu'il n'avait pas de
majorité au Parlement pour toucher à la
constitution sur ce sujet du référendum
sur l'immigration et en plein projet de
loi finalement au Parlement sur
l'immigration il a annoncé à la droite
qu'il n'y aurait pas de possibilité de
référendum sur ce sujet qu'il fermait la
porte euh justement sur cette question
et donc c'était euh peut-être un autre
point qui a tendu encore un peu plus la
relation entre la majorité
présidentielle et les LR sachant que les
Français étaient favorables à la
révision constitutionnelle pour dépasser
les référendums sur les questions de
société et élargir un peu à à
l'immigration ouais et alors on va
parler des conséquences euh pour
l'exécutif hein on commence à regarder
le baromètre mensuel comme tous les mois
vous avez posé la question de la côe de
popularité euh d'Emmanuel Macron
d'Élisabeth band sont-ils un bon
Président de la République une bonne
Premier ministre c'est un baromètre qui
a été réalisé après le vote de la motion
de Roger Erwan on va voir les résultats
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron et ellisabeth
borne payent le rejet de ce texte à
l'Assemblée la semaine dernière oui
absolument et c'est c'est d'ailleurs
intéressant de de regarder la
trajectoire sur cette année vu qu'on est
au mois de décembre de regarder la
trajectoire 2023 d'Emmanuel Macron en
terme de popularité il avait perdu
beaucoup de points de popularité on l'a
vu au premier semestre avec la réforme
des retraites il y a une légère remontée
à la rentrée une attitude du président
qui a été saluée
face au conflit israélo-palestinien mais
globalement là avec ce nouveau recul de
la popularité de chef de l'État au
global il perd 8 point sur l'année 2023
ce qu'on évoquait le mois dernier
c'était le risque d'un vote sanction aux
élections européennes qui sera la la
première élection où les Français
retournent aux urnes après la séquence
présidentielle législative mais
maintenant à cette question du vote
sanction aux européen c'est à c'est à
ajouter un risque de vote critique face
à l'ingouvernabilité parce que que le le
réformisme dynamique pour décloisonner
la France rendre l'action publique
efficace c'était quand même un des
marqueurs d'Emmanuel Macron et de sa
compétence et de sa capacité à faire
changer les choses si aujourd'hui il est
dans une ingouvernabilité et il montre
que finalement ses projets à chop ça
sappe quand même beaucoup son crédit et
auprès de son socle électoral donc il il
y a un risque qui va au-delà du vote
sanction et de la surmobilisation des
oppositions au aux européennes mais qui
est vraiment dans la confiance dans le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron et dans sa
capacité à réformer ouais on voit donc
Emmanuel MACR qu'on perd des points
ellisabeth borne aussi perd des points
elle perd un point clair est-ce que elle
paye cette séquence oui elle était sur
une dynamique très négative hein depuis
depuis longtemps le mois dernier déjà
c'était une des des responsables qui qui
qui étai la plus pénalisé par par cette
séquence on on la voyait enfin on
demandait son départ et là c'est sûr que
elle a à la fois joué un rôle assez
central c'est-à-dire que dans son face-
àface avec Géral d'manin elle a elle a
tenté voilà de de reprendre la main mais
que voilà cette impass dans laquelle il
se trouve trouve à trouver une majorité
à élargir la majorité à trouver une
façon de gouverner malgré l'absence de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée montre
cet échec et et cet
impasse on va je continuer justement à
parler de ce projet de loi immigration
on va revenir évidemment sur le le
baromètre mais puisqu'on parle des
conséquences pour l'exécutif et pour la
majorité de cette séquence Alex est-ce
que finalement le plus dur c'est pas la
journée d'aujourd'hui oui le programme
d'aujourd'hui s'annonce chargé avec la
reprise de la commission mixte paritaire
ce matin à 10h30 députés et sénateurs
vont essayer de lever le point de
blocage notamment sur la question du
versement de l'allocation logement de
des aides personnalisées au logement
pour les étrangers en espérant qu'il ne
trouve pas d'autres point de blocage
dans l'examen de ce projet de loi
immigration en tout cas à 10h30 et bien
Bruno rotaillo le président du groupe LR
au Sénat ne sera pas présent dans cette
commission mixte paréire il l'a annoncé
ce matin sur ce plateau il
s'explique 10h30 c'est le
début de la réunion des groupes moi ce
matin j'irais chercher un mandat auprès
de mon groupe je n'irai pas à la CMP
j'estime que ma place c'est devant mon
groupe pour le présider pour expliquer
les choses et pour recevoir de la part
des sénateurs LR un mandat clair je ne
ferai rien qui soit en contradiction
avec ce que veut mon groupe je serai
devant mon groupe et je ne serai pas la
commission x voilà doncon o qui a besoin
de consulter le groupe les républicains
au Sénat sur cette négociation en CMP et
si au final il y a accord entre la
majorité présidentiel et les
républicains sur ce projet de loi
immigration et bien à 14h30 ce qui est
prévu c'est que l'ensemble du Sénat se
prononce par un vote sur ce texte de
compromis issu de la commission mixte
paritaire alors là il ne devrait pas y
avoir trop de problème he la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat devrait
voter ce projet de loi immigration en
revanche là où ça va être intéressant à
observer c'est aux alentours de 16h
16h30 à l'Assemblée nationale après les
questions au Gouvernement et bien les
députés devront aussi voter sur ce
projet de loi immigration issue de cette
négociation et il faudra voir si la
cinquantaine de voix de députés les
républicains qui pourraiit être gagner
en faveur de ce projet de loi
immigration ne sera pas perdu de l'autre
côté au sein de la majorité
présidentielle car certains député
Renaissance pourrait ne pas voter un
texte jugé trop droitier on va écouter
un député Renaissance qui était
interrogé sur le plateau d' LCP à hier
soir il est minuit euh et donc demain
nous aurons peut-être un texte de toute
façon ce texte là s'il ne respecte pas
les lignes rouges que nous avons définis
et qui ont fait l'objet de discussion ce
weekend entre forces républicaines et
bien nous serons un certain nombre à ne
pas la voter et donc moi je dis à nos
représentants dans la CMP de ne pas
céder s'ils veulent que ce texte soit
voté demain alors ça c'est c'est accord
qu'est-ce qui se passe juste en cas
d'échec Alex et bien en cas d'échec le
projet lis immigration est abandonné par
le gouvernement c'est Emmanuel Macron
qui la semaine dernière avait fixé cet
ultimatum il veut clore cette séquence
immigration avant Noël ce serait à la
fois un échec pour le gouvernement pour
la majorité présidentielle mais aussi
pour la majorité de droite et du centre
du Sénat qui souhaitait un texte de loi
sur l'immigration la majorité Elisabeth
borne joue gros aujourd'hui clair ah bah
oui oui on l'a bien vu ils ont dit voilà
que si le texte il enfin il y a cette
question d'un accord maispr a le vote il
faut que arrivent à réunir leurs troupes
pour voter ce texte on dit qu'ils
utiliseraient pas le 493 que le texte
serait abandonné euh effectivement ce
qu'on disait s'il partait voilà cette
fin d'année en ayant échoué sur ce texte
fondamental où les Français ont pu voir
pendant des semaines des tractations une
ambiguïé sur les position voilà enfin le
le flou et et et l'accusation qui plane
de ne pas avoir de boussole de ne pas
avoir de projet d'avoir ce manque de
récit de ce qu'on veut faire là on
aurait une manifestation vraiment très
très importante de cette de cette
puissance en fait à à gouverner et
d'autant que si on revient au au
baromètre Erwan là aussi c'est question
que vous posez tous les mois c'est ce
qu'on appelle le palmares de l'adhésion
quelles sont les personnalités
politiques préférées on se rend compte
que dans la majorité et bien tout le
monde perd y compris Édouard Philippe
qui est à chaque fois numéro 1 de ce
baromètre alors il reste mais c'est
celui qui perd le plus de points oui
tout à fait c'est vrai que pour pour
pour la première fois la majorité alors
qu'elle en était l'instigatrice a été la
victime du en même temps c'estàd que les
oppositions et de gauche et de droite se
sont opposé à un projet de la de la
majorité et il y a il y a une
déflagration qui est importante pour
Elisabeth borne on peut se demander si
cette double séquence des retraites puis
maintenant de l'immigration n'a pas trop
entamer son capital de soutien dans
l'opinion et on voit des baisses pour
les figures de la majorité qui sont
significatives moins 5 points vous
l'avez dit pour Édouard Philippe moin 4
points pour Bruno Le Maire moin 4 points
pour Gérald armanin Gabriel hatal lui
qui avait présenté le choc des savoirs
entre-etemps qui avait été plutôt
apprécié à limité la voilà étaé épargné
mais c'est vrai que il y a un recul des
figures de la majorité parce que ça J le
discrédit sur la capacité à réformer sur
la maîtrise des des horloges et de la
boussole du du camp présidentiel qui
n'est plus assuré aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit des Français ouais et Gérald
armmanin moins qu points Erwan le disait
c'est aussi c'est la deuxième je crois
plus forte baisse he derrière Édouard
Philippe ça veut dire que la séquence
l'a abîmé politiquement clair tout à
fait on se souvient lundi dernier après
la la motion de reget il allé présenter
sa démission au président de la
République qui a qu' l'a refusé dans
coulisse on sait que voilà Isabel avait
tenté de le contacter mais il voilà il a
voulu que ce soit Macron qui refuse sa
sa démission il y a vraiment voilà une
une dimension enfin il a porté ce texte
il en avait fait voilà vraiment un
combat et puis sur on en avait parlé de
ce ce savoir-fire politicien de de
tractation voilà que dans cette ce h
clon encore une fois bah tout n'était
pas celé tout n'était pas ficelé et
c'est quand même un échec retentissant
euh donc on voit bien que c'était déjà
une personnalité clivante on en avait
longtemps parlé quand en juillet il
avait aspiré à à à à prendre la place
d'Isabe borne non finalement le la la
majorité n'était pas n'était pas soudé
autour de ce candidat qui avait des
positions jugé trop droitières et là bah
on est pile dedans c'est-à-dire que il a
voilà défendu un texte qui à l'image de
ses de ses convictions de son son sa sa
stratégie de contournement du RN en
reprenant certaines des idées en
refusant de la de la diaboliser et on
voit que que ça coince que ça ne fait
pas consensus et que ça n'a pas réussi à
trouver un accord pour autant donc oui
je pense que cette cette séquence la l'a
bien on va dire marginalisé d'une
certaine façon dans dans la séquence et
en revanche on le voit dans le baromètre
ceux qui prennent des points c'est Eric
soioti Mario maréchal Jordan Bardella ça
veut dire que la séquence profite à la
droite et à l'extrême droite en tout cas
elle profite surtout à l'extrême droite
parce que c'est vrai qu'elle ne profite
pas à la gauche en tout cas elle est
plutôt vue comme un échec pour la
majorité à l'extrême droite c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a marine Le Pen en 3è
position des personnalités politiques
qui ont les codes d'adhésion les plus
imp importante chez les Français Jordan
Bardella 4e Marion maréchal 5e et en
fait pour expliquer ça il y a quand même
deux choses il y a d'une part la
droitisation des des Français on le voit
bien finalement les les personnalités de
gauche arrivent assez loin dans notre
palmarès et puis il y a aussi quand même
il faut pas l'ignorer un recentrage de
ces personnalités qui sont moins
considérés aujourd'hui comme des
personnalités d'extrême droite avec des
des thèmes qui rentent dans le débat on
le voit bien justement avec ce projet de
loi immigration avec des des thèmes qui
ne sont plus du tout jugés extrêm mais
dans le débat et c'est vrai que le le
regain des inquiétudes sur la sécurité
et l'immigration joue en leur faveur
aussi dans dans l'actualité on va parler
des européennes puisque c'est le thème
du baromètre ce mois-ci le scrutin on le
rappelle c'est le 9 juin prochain on va
découvrir les résultats des intentions
de vote selon ce baromètre on rappelle
juste qu'il faut faire plus de 5 % pour
obtenir des sièges au Parlement européen
le RN arrive largement en tête loin
derrière Renaissance et très loin
derrière les autres partis on est dans
un duel Awan oui alors on est dans un
duel mais avec des dynamiques
complètement inversées c'estàd que le le
le RN a vraiment le le vent pou 31 %
d'intention de vote c'est un niveau très
haut ils sont 10 points au-dessus la la
liste de la majorité présidentielle
c'est un mécanisme complètement inversé
par rapport à ce qu'on voyait en 2019 si
on rappelle le contexte de 2019 la liste
de Nathalie l'oiseau était placée
beaucoup plus haut dans les sondages
pour un atterrissage à 22 % avec une
campagne qui avait déjà été vécu comme
une contreperformance parce que sur le
fil elle s'était faite doublé par la
liste de Jordan Bardella qui avait
remonté dans les dernières semaines de
la campagne aujourd'hui le RN part en
tête et avec un matelas de de soutien
qui est beaucoup plus important et
probablement plus fidélisé qu'il ne
l'était par le passé parce que pendant
longtemps le RN c'était un parti qui
craignait beaucoup de la démobilisation
électorale parce que c'était un socle
électoral composé de jeunes d'ouvriers
de personnes qui qui se démobilisent
facilement dans les urnes alors que la
majorité présidentielle est plutôt
soutenue par les 65 ans et plus les
cadres qui votent beaucoup aujourd'hui
on voit que le RN n'a plus de faiblesse
électorale et même si je regarde les
résultats de notre intention de vote
auprès des 65 ans et plus auprès des
cadres auprès des habitants de métropole
j'arrive quand même à 20 points
d'intention de vote pour le le
rassemblement national donc c'est un
matelas assez solide avec une une vraie
prise de hauteur par rapport à la
majorité présidentielle il y avait un
point d'écart en 2019 au soir des
élections européennes il y en a 10 dans
notre intention de vote ça veut pas dire
que c'est le scénario final on est à 6
mois du scrutin mais ça montre qu'il y a
quand même un vrai écart entre les deux
et le RN en verrait si les élections
avaient lieu dimanche prochain 29
députés au Parlement EUR c'est c'est
ne9f de plus que la majorité
présidentielle le Ren en gagnerait 6 la
majorité présidentielle en perdrait
trois donc il y a vraiment deux écarts
et des des dynamiques électorales qui
sont complètement inverses entre ces
deux forces politique clair est-ce que
ça veut dire que Marine Le Pen et
Jordane Bardella réussissent leur Paris
de faire de ses européennes une élection
de mandat et donc un duel avec Emmanuel
Macron effectivement c'était c'était la
stratégie le directeur de campagne
Alexandre Loubé n Le redit ce matin dans
les quotidiens du cé bras notre
stratégie est validée euh cette barre
des 30 % était vraiment un objectif pour
eux et là bah on voit que à 6 mois des
élections il est atteint dans les
intentions de vote ils ont démarré très
tôt avec le choix donc de de nommer
Jordane Bardella à tête de cette liste
alors que on voit que dans les autres
formations il y a encore des
atternoimand on ne sait pas encore qui
conduira la liste Renaissance même si
voilà ça se ça se ça se dessine mais
voilà donc il a il y a vraiment une
volonté d'aller d'aller l'avant avec
cette crainte quand même effectivement
d'une démobilisation qui va être le gros
gros enjeu pour ser quiia a une très
grosse avance mais mais s'assurer que
cet électorat se présente bien à ces
élections européennes où
traditionnellement il y a une très forte
abstention herwan l' dit contrairement
effectivement à l'électorat de la de la
majorité qui qui vote beaucoup à ce à ce
scrutin là et donc l'idée c'est de
montrer que de la même façon qu'il
peuvent mettre le gouvernement en
minorité aujourd'hui sur un débat comme
il y a à l'Assemblée bah au Parlement
européen ils pourraient avec leurs
alliés populistes
européens contrer en fait la majorité
pro-européenne sur des dossiers comme on
voit qui sont en train d'être traités
aujourd'hui l'environnement
l'immigration donc il y a vraiment cette
volonté de de jouer ce jeu-là ouais et
justement à l'échelle de toute l'Europe
quand on regarde les sondages en France
et bien il y a pas un reflet identique
sur les sondages au niveau de tout le
Parlement européen il y a bien une
poussée des formations d'extrême droite
mais il reste quand même dans les
sondages de blocs forts du Parti
populaire européen c'est-à-dire la
droite et des sociaux des démocrate mais
effectivement selon les intentions de
vote au niveau européen et bien il y
aura une poussée des deux groupes
d'extrême droite à savoir et bien
identité démocratie où il y a les
députés français du RN et également les
conservateurs et réformistes européens
où il y a par exemple la formation de
l'Italienne Georgia Méloni pour voir la
suite des intentions de vote Erwan les
autres partis sont en dessous de 10 %
c'est le PS et les LR qui arrivent en
tête de ce deuxè blot on va dire ils
sont à 9 % tous les deux oui pour le le
PS c'est assez intéressant parce que il
retrouve en quelque sorte le le
leadership au au sein de la gauche ça ça
montre quand même une rupture avec la
situation de 2022 à la création de
l'anupes où le centre de gravité naturel
et légitime de l'accord était la France
insoumise on voit qu'on est plus dans
cette situation faut préciser quand même
que le le PS à 9 % bénéficie aussi de de
la structuration des forces politiques
c'est qu'il y a pas de liste génération
il y avit une génération qui avait fait
tris points en en 2019 le le PS était à
6 points donc voilà on est quand même
sur la même tendance mais ça place le PS
en première position la force politique
qui est la plus affectée par la nouvelle
donne électorale c'est les écologistes
les écologistes aujourd'hui
recueilleraiit 6 % des des voix serait 7
points de moins que la performance de
2019 il perdrait sièges au au Parlement
européen c'est la la force politique qui
perdrait le plus si les les les
résultats électoraux étit conforme à ce
qu'on a a mesuré dans notre sondage
c'est ce qui est important c'est que on
est sur une une candidate politique qui
est beaucoup moins rassembleuse que n'a
pu l'être Yannick jade en 2019 Daniel
conbendit en 2009 on est sur un résultat
proche de la liste d'Emmanuel Kos en en
2014 très rapidement clairire il nous
reste 20 non non mais je effectivement
sur le PS on revient sur ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure la droitisation peut-être
de la majorité peut aussi bénéficier
aujourd'hui le le candidatatif c'est
Raphael gluxman enfin il y a des des des
négociations mais c'est que c'estes pris
de position notamment sur l'Ukraine sur
les réfugiés sur sur les droits de
l'homme enfin une certaine
positionnement a pu ramener un électorat
qui se retrouve pas dans la dans la
nuupesse en fait aujourd'hui et on
suivra évidemment ces européenes on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler avec vous on va
parler de la loi immigration la une de
la presse
[Musique]
régionale Alex le projet de
l'immigration à la unee de certains de
nos quotidiens régionaux et oui Emmanuel
Macron joue à l'apprenti sorcier selon
la Marseillaise le quotidien marseillais
estime qu'Emmanuel Macron a céder aux
républicains qui ont multiplié les
exigences pour durcir le projet de loi
immigration soulignant encore un peu
plus et bien la crise de régime en cours
et puis de de son côté Anice matin a
rencontré des étrangers qui sont
employés dans des métiers dans des
secteurs en tension on le rappelle hein
ce texte prévoit la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension même si la droite
sénatoriale a durci les critères de
réular de régularisation par le préfet
et Alex si le gouvernement connaît des
difficultés sur cette loi immigration en
2024 il y aura une autre loi qui
pourrait être compliquée à faire adopter
c'est la loi sur la fin de vie et oui
les ennuis ne sont pas terminés hein
pour Emmanuel Macron ce texte sur la fin
de vie n'est pas encore présenté
officiellement qu'il suscite déjà des
critiques he une version provisoire
prévoit la création de deux aides
actives à mourir le suicide assisté et
une exception d'euthanasie par le
soignant quand la personne en fin de vie
ne peut pas recourir elle-même au
suicide assisté et ce texte et bien il
suscite l'inquiétude des soignants c'est
à la Une des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace des organisations disent leur
opposition à je cite une mort provoquée
et organisée alors que l'accès au soins
palliatifs est déjà insuffisant dans
notre pays mauvaise nouvelle pour les
fates de fin d'année le covid est de
retour et oui le nombre de contamination
du covid augmente avec notamment le
nouveau variant jN1 le plan blanc a été
activé dans les hôpitaux du Grand Est et
puis quand à la une du Courrier Picard
on apprend le retour du masque
obligatoire au au CHU d'Amien dans cet
hôpital et bien les soignants les
patients les visiteurs devont remettre
le masque car il y a le covid mais il
aussi la grippe qui circule pour des
Bones nouvelles Alex merci merci Claire
mercian merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
Alex on donne rendez-vous à nos
téléspectateurs à 1230 parce qu'on va
suivre bien sûr ce qui se passe ce matin
autour de cette commission mixte paréire
prochain rendez-vous donc à 12h30 on
vous retrouve en direct très bonne
matinée